the North remembers we know no king but
the King in the north whose name is
stark I don't care whose have busted
that starts blood runs through his veins
he's my king from this day until his
last day what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
video I recently made a video where I
listed some of the greatest fighters
that are still currently alive in this
show and this led to many different
discussions about not only the greatest
fighters but some of the greatest fight
scenes as well so today I figured I
would talk about just that in today's
video I want to go over some of the
great boss fights so this show has given
us over the course of seven seasons I
did not want to rank them this time but
I did want to put them in some sort of
order so I will go over them by order of
appearance and the show which means I
will start with season 1 then work my
way up to season 7 there are a bunch of
different scenes that I want to show you
so let's get started right away
in the very first season of the show we
were given just a taste of what could
possibly be the greatest fight of all
time I am convinced that if Robert
Baratheon did not stop this fight the
Clegane brothers would have fought till
the death but it just ended up being one
of the biggest teases in television
history the good thing is both of these
characters are still alive well sort of
but I think most of us are expecting to
see this fight pick back up where it
left off only this time it will end with
at least one of these characters being
dead just imagine a climactic battle
between two of the best and biggest
fighters in Westeros with the added rage
of a lifetime of resentment and you have
cleganebowl this is arguably one of the
most anticipated show downs this brief
sword fight between the Clegane
brother's happened during season 1
episode 5 but what is interesting is
this was not the only boss fight that
happened in this episode
[Music]
the fight between Jaime Lannister and
Ned Stark did not happen in the books
this was one of the changes that the
show made and I personally like this
change it might not have been the
greatest sword fight in the show but it
certainly raised the stakes
now we all know Jaime is a far superior
swordsman than Ned Stark but I thought
it was kind of interesting that one of
the Lannister Guardsmen thought it was
necessary to stab Ned from behind Jaime
Lannister pretty much considered himself
to be invincible at this point but even
though Ned Stark was a much older man he
was still able to defend himself quite
well which led to one of Jaime's men
intervening in this fight which really
pissed Jaime off because he felt like he
had to fight under control can you
imagine how different this story would
have been if Jaime ended up killing Ned
during this scene what would Catelyn
have done what Tyrion then I'm sure she
would have wanted to kill him but Cersei
still had her daughters whenever I think
back on this fight I always like to
imagine all the different scenarios that
could have played out if Jamie won or if
Ned won if Jaime and Ned would fight in
the books Jaime would win every single
time but let me ask all of you this if
Ned Stark would have not been stabbed in
the back of the leg how do you think
this fight would have ended in the show
I'm curious to see what some of you have
to say we are done with dancing for the
day
done to your father
I feel like I could not make this video
without adding this scene with Syrio
Forel his part on the show was very
similar to Oberyn Martell's he was only
in one season but he was very likeable
and he made a big impact on the
community this is probably one of the
more controversial scenes in this series
because of its ambiguous ending which
leads many fans into believing that
Syrio Forel is actually Jagan agar as
much as I enjoyed watching Syrio Forel
kick some Lannister ass you have to
admit this scene is also a little
ridiculous
Syrio Forel was only armed with a wooden
sword but he still managed to knock down
several men who were wearing armor from
head to toe on the other hand what I do
love about this scene is the fact that
Serio did not back down from this fight
he put his own life on the line in order
to buy Arya some time he was ready to
give his life so that his students life
had a chance at having some kind of a
future and that's just one of the many
reasons why I love the character Syrio
Forel
[Music]
[Music]
this fight did actually happen in the
books but it played out a little
differently Brienne is an amazing
fighter on the show but she's not quite
as good in the books Jamie on the other
hand is well known as one of the
greatest fighters of all time Brienne is
certainly amongst the elite sword
fighters in the realm at the time of her
fight with Jamie but she is not better
than him
they're not even in the same league
Jamie is what you would call a prodigy
and he has been since a very young age
you have to remember that at the time of
this fight
Jamie had been a prisoner for about a
year he wasn't able to train or even
hold a sword during that time when they
fight each other in the books Jamie does
think to himself that Brienne is
stronger than him and the thought of
that gave him chills but later when
brian is reflecting on their fight
she knows that no one in the Seven
Kingdoms would be a match for Jamie when
he is healthy but with all that being
said this was still a very fun fight to
watch because we got to see two top
characters test their skills against one
another even though it was a little
unfair for Jamie but I'm glad their
fight was included in the show
now this was fantastic because it
actually ended with the death of beric
Dondarrion well for a short period of
time until thoris of mayer brought him
back to life
i still remember what it felt like when
i saw this scene for the first time
because i thought it was a big moment in
the show now that they have introduced
characters being brought back to life
this changes everything in george RR
martin even admitted this was the
foreshadowing for what would later
happened with John Snow this is still
one of my favorite scenes today you have
beric Dondarrion with his flaming sword
and you have the Hound one of the most
badass characters of all time but he
also has a fear of fire The Hound has to
face his fear in order to have a chance
at freedom and it won't end until
someone is dead then we get the creepy
resurrection immediately afterwards this
fight had all the ingredients to make a
really cool scene that I think fans will
remember for a very long time
I never fight in a castle believe it or
not but Jon Snow actually learned a lot
from this fight what Karl Tanner the
fukken legend from gin alley John was
getting his ass kicked during this fight
because karl was not afraid to fight
dirty and John later adopted some of
these methods what's he used when he
fought the Magnar during the attack on
the wall John realized that in order to
survive sometimes you need to get your
hands dirty and that's exactly what he
did when John fought Karl Tanner I think
a lot of people were disappointed
because he may not have won this fight
if it wasn't for one of Craster's
daughters however I still think this is
one of the greatest death scenes in the
entire show it's also a nice reference
to the books because this is how biter
dies when he is pummeling Brienne of
Tarth no matter how cool a sword through
the back of the head may look it will
never compare to this next scene because
this one is known to make people's heads
explode
[Applause]
I still say this has to be one of the
greatest moments in television history
not only do you have two amazing
fighters battling it out to the death
but Tyrion freakin Lannister's life hung
in the balance
even the scene leading up to the trial
by combat was amazing when Oberyn
Martell told Tyrion the story about
meeting him when he was still a baby
then he declares himself Tyrion champion
before he leaves the cell Oberyn Martell
was an amazing character with an even
better screen presence he wasn't in the
show or the books for very long but he
made one hell of an impact during his
time in this story I'm pretty sure that
almost everyone wanted Oberyn to win I
know I was crushed when he lost but I
must say it made from one iconic scene
that fans won't soon forget
oberyn's vengeance was righteous but
unfortunately it alternately got him
killed
you could say that thanks to some occult
a nurse dirty tricks a led to Jon Snow
winning this fight and I think it's safe
to say that season four was a big
turning point for Jon Snow he was always
a well trained swordsman but he had
never had any real fighting experience
outside of the training yard he had
trouble we've been holding onto his
sword every time he got into a fight but
by this point Jon is no longer just
well-trained he is now an experienced
warrior and his toughest task is still
yet to come
[Music]
this is another one of my personal
favorite fights from the show although
it is a massive change from the books
because these two characters have never
fought before this fight scene was a
little controversial to say the least
I think almost everyone considers the
Hound to be a better fighter than
Brienne but she clearly won this fight
but you have to remember you've got to
consider all the variables the Hound was
weakened and he possibly had an infected
wound on his shoulder because he refused
to allow Arya to properly fix it
whereas Brienne was well fed and rested
she also had the best armor money could
buy and a better sword than money could
buy because it was forged of Valyrian
steel the end of this fight also had a
very big impact on the hounds
transformation as a character this
stone-cold killer continues to grow as
one of the show's most sympathetic
characters because we have all seen how
far he has come and I think we would all
like to see him make it to the finish
line and hopefully kill his own brother
Gregor Clegane
unfortunately sir Barristan the bold had
fallen but the legendary Knight went
down fighting and he took about a dozen
men with him
sir Barristan Selmy knew the task of
escaping the sons of the harpy was near
impossible he was fighting multiple men
far younger than he was in a crowded
space where he could be cornered and
overwhelmed very easily yet he kept on
fighting and doing his best until his
last breath as fun as it was to see
Barristan carve through a dozen men like
he was carving through a cake this scene
pissed a lot of people off this
character is still alive in the books
but the show decided to dispose of this
character in a back alley in Mereen it
was sad to see sir Barristan go but this
makes me even more curious to know what
happens with this character in the books
I would love to see him return to
Westeros with a very big army behind him
and three very large dragons above him
[Music]
this was another one of the
game-changing moments in the television
show we already knew dragonglass could
kill the white walkers
but Valyrian steel had never been tested
until now and it worked in dramatic
fashion
both Jon Snow and the white Walker were
shocked when Longclaw was able to stop
the magical ice sword but it was even
more exciting when Jon sliced through
the white Walker shattering him into a
thousand pieces of ice this even caught
the attention of the night king and he
was obviously very intrigued by what he
had seen every time a white Walker dies
we learn a little bit more about their
weaknesses
Sam Tarly was able to confirm that
dragon glass can kill them Jon was able
to confirm that Valyrian steel can kill
them then when Jon killed another one in
season seven it proved that not only
does the white Walker die but so do all
of the whites that that white Walker
raised himself this new revelation led
to beric Dondarrion suggesting that if
you can kill the night king then his
entire army should fall right along with
him since he turned them all it's a very
interesting theory but we will have to
wait and see what happens when an if it
has ever put to the test
no me did but the story a thousand times
[Music]
well I think it is safe to say this may
be one of the most important moments in
the history of the story this was a day
that Ned Stark had only dreamed about
but we only get bits and pieces of what
actually happened we obviously knew
there was a fight and as the two parties
engage in battle Ned hears his sister
crying out his name and the dream
concludes with him making a promise
before she dies so far in the novel's
what exactly this promise entailed is
unclear it has never revealed exactly
how the battle unfolded such as who
killed who or in what manner all that is
known is that Ned Stark and Howland Reed
were the only survivors thankfully in
season six we got answers to so many of
these questions and now that we know who
Jon Snow's parents actually are this
makes John Snow the true heir to the
Iron Throne so this moment in history
will obviously have a major impact on
the end game of the series it will be
very interesting to see what Jon Snow
decides to do with this information
considering the woman he is falling in
love with believes she was born to rule
the Seven Kingdoms when the truth of
what happened at the Tower of joy
becomes public knowledge it is bound to
send shockwaves across Westeros and I
can't wait to see the look on some of
the characters faces when they find out
who Jon Snow really is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
but let me know what you thought about
the list were there any other boss
fights you would have added put your
thoughts down below in the comment
section I want to thank you all for
stopping by and watching the video I
really appreciate that and I also want
to thank everyone on patreon for
continuing to support my channel thank
you very much I hope you all have a
great day I'll see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]